[Music]
who
are the lovers being referenced in the
title of philip jose farmer's
controversial novella
the lovers well we have some names one
of them
is the main character of the work we're
introduced to him in chapter one
hal yaro and the other one is
introduced fairly early on once hal has
landed on
the planet oz again and he's out going
to inspect some some ruins with
his gap and with two of the woggle bugs
and her name is jeannette rasignac
and you know you can tell by that that
she's french derived
right in fact her father as she tells us
was a frenchman um and she speaks
a kind of dialect of french that has
according to to hal degenerated from the
original french so what we've got here
is
a in some respects kind of like first
contact right
between an earth man the space fairer
from earth
hal who comes from the hijack
community on earth one of the big four
of the
post-apocalyptic states and then what
appears to be
an inhabitant of ozigan but it turns out
to be
a lot more complicated than that
and hal is a linguist right he's a
jack-of-all-trades linguist
so and he's actually spent some time
with french speakers
uh in the reserve up in
near the arctic circle with the few
i think he mentions 20 or so descendants
of the french canadians that are left
so he's able to figure out her language
but she's also
able to learn american very quickly
as well we get her origin story
right uh with hal uh asking her her
questions actually
there's all sorts of questions that he
he asks and she's
talking to him and she says i followed
you and listened to you talk i could not
understand you but after a while
i heard you respond to the name hal euro
learning your name was nothing at all
what puzzled me was that you and that
other man
looked like my father must be human
beings yet because you did not speak my
father's language you could not have
come from this
his planet then i thought of course my
father had once told me that his people
had come to
wabofi that's her name for oz again from
another planet so it was a matter of
logic you must
be there from the original world of
human beings and she says
yes yes my father jean-jacques rastinock
was born on another planet he came to
this one from that
his ancestors came to that other planet
which revolves around a star
far from here from an even more distant
star
and then hale says oh they must have
been colonists from
earth but there's no record of that and
it goes down a little bit further
and she says all i know is what my
father told
me he said that he and some others found
oz again
during a exploration they landed on this
continent his comrades were killed
he found my mother your mother worse and
worse hal said groaning
she was an indigene her people have
always been here
they built this city they and your
father was an earth man and you were
born of his
this union with an oscar humanoid
impossible
the chromosomes of your father and
mother could not possibly have matched
i do not care about these chromosomes
said jeannette in a quavering voice you
see me before you do you not
i exist do i not my father lay with my
mother and here i
am deny me if you can so what we've got
here is
somebody who's actually in some respects
half alien
from the terran perspective right her
father is a frenchman
turns out that her father she's going to
mention later on was was very virile
and not only got her mother pregnant but
also
her aunts and they had many children and
she's she's one of them
so she meets him out there and
this presents certain problems because
the the you know the wobble bugs
according to jeanette
have been bad to her they've mistreated
her they've imprisoned her she's trying
to stay away from them
as much as possible and the
hijack confederacy that hal is a member
of is a very repressive
society ruled over by a state church the
starch right
and so he can't afford
to have her found out by them although
of course as we discover
near the very end some of them did in
fact
know about what was going on and have
been have been tracking him
so what do we have uh take place he goes
he takes a
flyer and brings her back and
installs her in his apartment
as somebody who's living there in secret
and there they get to have a
life together there they become the
lovers
as a matter of fact in the very
beginning
of that relationship here we go there's
a great scene here
he finally found the key but had trouble
inserting it he was breathing hard by
the time
he succeeded in opening the door he
almost pushed jeanette through
she had taken her mask off wait hell she
said leaning her weight against his
haven't you forgotten something
oh forerunner what could it be something
serious no i only thought she smiled and
then lowered her lids
that it was the tear in custom for men
to carry their brides across the
threshold
that is what my father told me his jaw
dropped bride she was
certainly taking a lot for granted and
this is sort of
a great vignette the thing that follows
here of
how their relationship proceeds he
couldn't take time to argue
without a word he swept her up in his
arms and carried her into the apartment
there he put her down and said back as
soon as possible
if anyone knocks or tries to get in hide
in that special chamber
i had the [ __ ] carpenter build for you
inside our closet don't make a sounder
come out
until you're sure it's me she suddenly
put her arms around him and kissed him
moshe things were going
so fast he didn't say a word or even
return her kiss
vaguely he felt that her words applied
to him were somewhat ridiculous
if he translated her degenerate french
correctly she had called him her dear
her big strong
man right and then the the very end of
this
he had a feeling jeanette was not going
to be the frigid mate
so much admired officially by the starch
so she's a different kind of woman than
he
is used to and he's a rather repressed
guy in part because of his upbringing
and you know his his life in the starch
and then continuing
that through she is uninhibited she
is much more lively and here we have
some
really important cultural differences
that are depicted
and then gradually eroded throughout the
story and this figures into how they're
lovers
so eating together there's a discussion
early on which i'm not going to
read from i'll just reference it
in which he wants her to put on
an apparatus so that he cannot
see her eating cannot see food going
into that disgusting masticating
mouth this is the custom for people
in the hijack confederacy that hal
is from as a matter of fact he says can
you keep your eating sounds
down i don't want to get grossed out by
you and this is going to be
referenced several different times over
the course of the story
he will get over this but he's not going
to get over it completely until
much later on alcohol
officially forbidden by the starch
except for you know medicinal purposes
or that sort of thing
uh hal is not a drinker jeanette is a
drinker she says
she tells him a story that the woggle
bugs got her addicted to alcohol and now
she's an alcoholic and
this actually leads to an entire
adventure that takes place
uh in the midpoint of the novel going
out to get some
of the the alcohol he actually hal
tries to wean her off of it giving her
an alcohol substitute
later on because he doesn't want her to
be an alcoholic but he will also start
drinking as well and she
gets him to have cocktails you know
where you can't taste the
alcohol quite so much and that's going
to produce an important difference
lipstick is one of the very first things
that's referenced as a matter of fact
when he first encounters her and sees
her crimson
lips he and realizes that she's wearing
cosmetics
he thinks that she might be a demonic
being the
wife of the forerunners uh you know evil
brother
and and they say oh that can't be the
case but he's kind of
you know both attracted and repulsed by
and really
we could say fascinated by her use of
lipstick and this is stuff by the way
that other women on earth are
using just not in the hijack confederacy
sex and intimacy huge huge matter right
it takes him a long time
to loosen up and to
be okay with with doing things
as a matter of fact she has to teach him
how to kiss
because kissing is not something that
they really do back
home for him um she you know he
first he's like you know too too little
then too much and then just
right so that that plays an important
role
as well she is is quite uninhibited you
know at one point she says i thought we
were going to sleep together
and and he's like really that that's
that's a big deal
um crying even you know displaying
it's okay to display like say anger or
contempt or things like that although
not to verbalize it
as such within hal's former world
back in the hijack confederacy ruled by
the the starch
as we see with his his former wife
but crying um
actually expressing your emotions in
open and healthy ways is something
that it you know jeanette does fairly
automatically
and hal has to take a while to
get used to he doesn't quite know what
to do when she first starts crying right
and the story of their love affair
is one of hal gradually
loosening up as a matter of fact the way
the farmer depicts hell
he's kind of a prig you know kind of a
prude and
you know makes her feel bad makes
jeanette feel bad
about some of the desires
and actions that she routinely
engages in the eating is a prime example
right
and so what are the grand themes of this
hal comes to realize that
the inhibitions that he feels are not
something natural
they are something that has been
implanted within him conditioning
is is the word that hal uses for himself
in thinking about these things
that there's been a kind of alienation
of himself
from his own body and his capacities
for engaging another human being as a
matter of fact i think if you're
you know looking at the difference
between jeanette
and um his his former wife who he leaves
behind
uh and officially you know gets a
divorce from
as he's taking off her oz again you know
they have sex but they have sex in a
very mechanical
um way that's that's you know there's
really no intimacy there whatsoever it's
an attempt to create
procreation he comes to be able to
enjoy and desire sex from this
you know beautiful interesting loving
woman who he has discovered on an
alien world but it takes him a lot you
know step by step by step
also with her agency she is the one who
is helping to bring him
out of this out of this conditioning
there's also a really interesting
point where there's a discussion of what
he calls
moral lecture 1816
right let me read a little bit before
this
so this is uh
they have a fight she says i thought you
loved me
and hal's staring and
she was twisting something inside of him
he had to straighten it out
when he entered the front room he saw
she was looking down cast for a while he
stood silent wanting to say
something but utterly unable to because
he'd never been
forced to solve such a problem before
hijacked women didn't cry
often and if they did they wept alone in
privacy he sat down by her and put his
hand on her soft shoulder
jeanette she turned quickly and laid her
dark hair against his chest she said
between sobs
i thought maybe you didn't love me and i
couldn't stand it not after all i've
been through
well jeannette i didn't i mean i wasn't
he paused
he had no intention of saying he'd loved
her he'd never told
any woman he'd loved her not even mary
his former wife
nor had any woman ever told him and here
was this woman on a far away planet only
half human at that
taking it for granted that he was hers
body and self
now notice what he does and this is you
know where we see the conditioning
he began speaking in a soft voice words
came easily because he was quoting
moral lecture 1816
all beings with their hearts in the
right place are brothers
man and woman are brother and sister
love is everywhere but love
should be on a higher plane man and
woman should rightly loathe the beastly
act as something the great mind the
cosmic observer
has not yet eliminated in man's
evolutionary development
the time will come when children will be
produced through thought alone
meanwhile we must recognize sex as
necessary for only one reason children
slap his head ring and points a fire
world off into the blackness before his
eyes
it was a moment before he could realize
that jeanette had leaped to her feet
and slammed him hard with the palm of
her hand he saw her standing above
him with her eyes slitted in her red
mouth open and drawn back in a snarl
then she whirled and ran back in the
bedroom he got up and followed her
she was lying on the bed sobbing um you
know
and so there's this reaction that she's
having they also get into a very
interesting
discussion a little bit later on about
this all all men are brothers
thing well does that only include human
beings
what about somebody who's a hybrid like
her you know
um how does that work out
what about the wobble bugs are perhaps
all rational beings
that way there's also some very
important uh
discussions later on hal is having
with his his friend um uh
who turns out to be a psychologist uh
fobo right and
here's how it goes although he didn't
know it he was himself being cured by
fobo his almost daily talks with the
empathist installed doubts about the
religion and science
of the hijacks script moving down a
little bit
the [ __ ] challenged the mathematics of
the donologist
hell proved fobo disproved he pointed
out the mathematics was based mainly on
false to fact assumptions
and you know phobo goes on and then
a little bit later right after this
jeanette says that this this is actually
quite good for him
what's what's happening um
so the other thing that's that's
important in the gradually loosening up
hal loosens up about alcohol jeanette
using alcohol
imbibing alcohol with her it's alcohol
also becomes
for him a disinhibitor so
you know it allows them to more easily
have sex with each other and enjoy each
other's bodies
and the intimacy produced by that it
also allows him to overcome the disgust
reactions that he has
to her eating out in the open you know
putting food in her face and chewing it
up and swallowing it so
he finds that a little bit of alcohol
will take the edge off
about that meanwhile we also find out
that janette
herself is not a static character i
mentioned there's
agency there on her part in bringing hal
out of his shell
but she's also adapting to and loving
hal in a very important way she's got
these incredible
imitative capacities this is a little
bit of foreshadowing of course
that we had pointed out earlier hal
is very surprised how quickly
she has a she's been able to learn
english right and so he brings that up
[Music]
let's see here yeah
and she says yes i'm just very good at
picking up
these sorts of of things
so there's also a whole range of
domestic activities that she's engaged
in she enjoys
making new clothes for herself she
enjoys you know
cooking food so that he's got a dinner
to come home
to after his work she does all sorts of
things to make their place
better for him and she's not doing it as
like you know a power
imbalance the wife is the servant of the
husband no this is
her taking control over
the sphere that she has it's kind of
interesting
this reminds me of in aristotle's
nickel mccain ethics aristotle
because of the culture that he grew up
in
he thought of very rigid gender roles
for men and women
you know men were engaging in politics
or commerce or things outside of the
household
and within the household women ruled and
actually aristotle says that's the way
it ought to be
if a man is dominating the household
there's something wrong there he's
behaving tyrannically
and so within the household you know the
wife is
is the one who decides all of these
sorts of things
another key aspect that turns out to
have a biological
importance is sex with the lights on and
you know if you think about when
farmer is writing this
right in the 50s and then later you know
reappropriating it in the 1960s
that was kind of a taboo for a lot of
americans um
so the fact that jeanette is so
uninhibited that she
wants to not just leave the lights on
like a lackadaisical kind of thing she
wants to see her lover while they're
engaging
in sex this is something quite important
and then finally there is this concern
near the end when she is ill as it turns
out
she is actually dying and
she's concerned with one
thing well two things take me to my
aunts and sisters they'll know what to
do
this is the practical part but she says
hell will you always love
and and you know she's actually asked
a little bit earlier um
yeah she's worried that he won't love
her once she
finds out what she truly is and hal says
yes yes you
know that we've got more important
things to do than talk
about that and she's in the process of
dying calcifying as it is
but she's not just concerned with
her progeny she's not just concerned
with
making sure that all the practical
details are done
she's concerned with him continuing
to love her both after the revelation of
the kind of being that she is which is
not going to be human and
after her death so this is something
quite important she wants to love him
she also
wants to be loved by him beyond
the boundary of life and death
and so this is really quite a depiction
running throughout this this work of
what it means to be a lover and
i think farmer has actually done quite a
solid job
in portraying at least some of the
possibilities
of what genuine love and intimacy and
desire would be
between people as it's going to turn out
across
rational species
you